hey guys it's max in this video we are
comparing the brand new m1 powered
macbook pro against its biggest rival
the dell xps 13 and we're not only gonna
take a look at cpu and graphics
performance we're also gonna take a look
at
some gaming tests photo editing video
editing the performance when we unplug
this system
we're gonna look at our awesome thermal
cameras a real world ram stress test
speakers webcams and more let's start
out with the exterior differences and
you guys may notice that we have a
different hinge here and that is because
we have the two in one version of the
xps 13 9300
now it is almost identical to the
regular xps 13
but the screen can fold all the way
around
and there is a benefit to this design we
actually have vapor chamber cooling with
dual fans
so that means we should get some great
performance out of this i7
processor now the regular xps 13s those
are backordered for a bit so we were
able to get one of these to test it out
but it's still gonna be completely fair
and you guys might also notice that
there is a difference
size wise the xps 13s are smaller
and slightly lighter than the macbook
pro now as far as ports both of these
have
two usbc ports the dell actually has
thunderbolt 4 compared to thunderbolt 3
on the macbook but it does have usb 4.
one thing i like about the dell is that
one of your ports are on the right hand
side
and then you have another one on the
left hand side whereas the macbook it
keeps both
on the left makes it harder to plug in
multiple devices and gives you less
options for charging the other thing i
like about the dell is that we have a
micro sd card slot which is great for
photographers people that shoot
video makes it really convenient as far
as build quality both of these
are excellent the best of the best we
have solid aluminum
we have magnesium and carbon fiber here
let's go ahead and open these
up and check the hinge the dell actually
starts opening it pretty easily
and then it stops you guys saw that
right there both opened up fairly
quickly i don't know if the mac was
first maybe you guys saw it
in the camera but what i love about the
dell is that we have that windows hello
so that as soon as you open it up it
logs you in using facial recognition
which is great
with the mac you can use your apple
watch or you can use touch id
now the mac does have an always-on
design so you guys see before i even
opened it
it is here ready to log in and with the
windows laptops my other xps
if it's been sitting for a day it goes
into deep sleep and then it takes
quite a bit longer six seven seconds to
open up
now let's talk about the insides you
guys see we definitely have a difference
the xps has this carbon fiber soft touch
which does feel nice it doesn't get too
cold but it does pick up fingerprints
and grease pretty easily
the macbook has an all-aluminum design
it is colder to the touch and they'll
heat up
but it does feel more premium now as far
as the keyboards the dell xps feels
pretty decent but the two in one
actually has a little bit less travel
than the regular xps 13 probably because
they need
the extra space for vapor chamber so the
macbook's magic keys actually feel
better
than this xps but the regular one i
actually like that one better than the
max keyboard now as far as trackpads the
xps 13s have one of the best windows
trackpads they are responsive
you can use multiple gestures it is a
diving board design but it still feels
good to click
up at the top but with that said it
still cannot compete with the macbook
pros magnetic touchpad
you can adjust the feel of the click and
it's actually not clicking down
so you actually get a perfectly even
feel all around both
do have fingerprint sensors built into
the buttons and then the macbook of
course has
the touch bar some people like it some
people hate it
for me it's not that useful now let's
take a look at the displays and as far
as resolution
the macbook has a 4.1 million pixel
display compared to 2.3
on this dell xps now we do have the
1080p
model or slightly higher than that we
typically test out the 4k model so this
time
i decided to match these up more price
wise and so
i went with that option and that also
helps with battery life which we'll be
talking about in
just a bit the 4k option does look
sharper and i can tell that the macbook
display
does look sharper than 1080p but it also
drains a lot more battery life and it
costs like 300 bucks more
and of course the xps is a two on one so
it is a touch screen
and in my time with this and the
previous one i found it to be fairly
useful now as far as brightness both
these are rated at 500 nits i went ahead
and adjusted my top camera so they're
not blown out and it maxed out the
displays
and just looking at them straight on the
macbook pro does look
slightly brighter but off axis at an
angle from our side camera
the dell maintains its brightness really
well
now as far as reflections both are very
similar
and this hdr video looks fantastic on
both of them
and if i had to say it i actually might
see a little bit less reflections on the
xps
dell used to have really reflective
displays they have an awesome coating
now
so brightness and reflections and using
them in bright rooms and watching videos
is a non-issue now the macbook does have
a little bit deeper
blacks but it's fairly similar now as
far as colors both of these can display
the dci p3 color space as you guys could
see
the logo is showing up in previous dells
this would not work you'd be limited to
srgb
so dell has been making massive
improvements to their displays and even
though this is a 1080p
panel it is an excellent one with that
said
the macbook does have a slightly better
display it's sharper
it is actually slightly more color
accurate with better contrast but i
would no longer choose
one of these over the other based on the
displays and now let's go ahead and
compare
the speakers put on a pair of headphones
if you have some
and let's take a listen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below i will
tell you what i heard it's a pretty
drastic difference
now as far as sound quality the macbook
pro
definitely takes it there's a lot of
bass and mids
whereas the xps really lacks in that
area now as far as
loudness the xps actually peaked four
decibels higher than the macbook which
is
interesting now with this new m1 model
we compared it to
the previous one and it actually got
slightly quieter apple
tuned it to have better sound quality
but they lowered the volume a little bit
whereas dell this xps has the same
speakers as before
but it got louder and it seems like dell
actually lowered the mids in the bass
to get better loudness output so as far
as speakers this thing is definitely
loud enough it just doesn't sound as
good as the mac both of these laptops
feature 720p
webcams right now i'm recording with the
dell xps 9310 in a very well lit
environment
so this is the best video quality you
can expect
and this is the microphone quality from
the dell and this is the webcam and
microphone
quality with the new macbook pro the
hardware stayed the same as before but
apple said the new m1 chip
actually processes the video better so
let me know which one looks better and
which one
sounds better down in the comments
section below and now let's get into
performance we're going to start out
with the ssd test
both these machines have 512 gigabytes
of fast
ssd let's go ahead and get started that
is a pretty
big difference we have a thousand right
compared to two thousand
and nineteen hundred read compared to
twenty seven hundred that's a massive
difference now with our previous xps
videos we actually tested the one
terabyte model and that one
is close to the macbook pro but i guess
with 512 it is a bit slower now this two
on one you cannot upgrade the ssd it's
soldered in just like the mac
but if you get the standard xps you can
actually
switch out your ssd yourself which is
nice and now let's compare
web browsing performance i have chrome
opened up on both of these and we're
going to get started and we have a
results we have 155 compared to 208
155 is actually the highest i've ever
seen on an intel based machine thanks to
the 11th gen processor
but apple's m1 is wicked fast for web
browsing and simple tasks and now let's
compare the cpu performance i'm excited
to put it against intel's 11th
gen but i want to point out a couple
things first this thing can boost up to
4.7 gigahertz which is
crazy very high whereas the m1 max sits
at 3.2 gigahertz now before i get
started i do want to point out that
i do have a set to best performance
which you do have to change in windows
and with that if you buy one of these
machines you won't get the full
performance unless you open up dell
power management
then go to thermal management and then
set it to ultra
performance if you don't do this you
will never get the proper performance so
let's go ahead
and get started all right we have our
scores and
wow that's actually better than i
expected for single core we only have a
difference of about 220 so that's about
15
faster with the m1 mac but for a
multi-core
the mac is 40 faster
so this single core score is still
awesome it's the best i've ever seen
for an intel based system or amd but the
mac
is killing it now as you guys probably
noticed the xps is plugged in
our macbook pro is not it gets full
performance
no matter if it's plugged in or
unplugged so next what i want to do is
go ahead and
unplug this xps i'm gonna make sure that
we're still in
the best performance modes and i'm gonna
run this one more time
and we're gonna see do we maintain this
performance or do we lose performance
and if so
how much do we lose all right we are
done and man this is disappointing now
the single core score
it didn't drop by that much just by 100
points but the multi-core score
definitely took a massive hit and
comparing it to the m1 mac
the m1 is now instead of 40 faster it is
more than twice
as fast which is crazy and we are still
set to the highest performance modes
in all the options that we get with this
system now what i'm really curious about
is how this will impact
real-world performance so for example
photo editing video editing and other
tasks
if you're not able to be plugged in
we'll take a look at that in just a bit
and now
let's compare the graphics and this is
going to be interesting because 11gen
has the new xe graphics which is a big
step up
let's go ahead and run both of these the
results are in we have 17 and a half
thousand compared to 21
700 so the mac does win out it's about
25
faster but i do want to note that 17 500
is a massive
improvement compared to intel's 10th
generation graphics and this particular
xps has the best xe graphics
it's the highest ship that intel makes
so that is good performance but it's
still not as good as the mac
and now let's compare gaming performance
i have gfx bench opened up right here
which is going to
run a gaming fps test let's go ahead and
get started now of course with windows
based systems
most games just work and with the mac
a lot of games aren't currently working
of course we are going to get the
ability to play ipad games iphone
apps all of that's coming and more games
are being added as we speak so we are
going to be doing an ultimate gaming
test
with this macbook pro so make sure you
guys click that subscribe button if you
guys want to see it the scores are in
and this is very interesting we have
39.6 frames per second
on the intel based system and that is
actually pretty good
but on the mac side we have 81.2
frames per second slightly higher than
double which is
crazy and that just shows off the
efficiency using
apple's metal api with its own custom
chip
and in some of the real world gaming
tests that we've done and seen
the performance just doesn't make sense
apple is doing some crazy optimization
to get really good frame rates out of
games and now let's push these machines
to their limits using cinebench r20
before i do that i want to get an
initial thermal reading
so take a look at the xps it looks like
we have a hotspot there
about 36 degrees celsius and then
flipping over to the macbook
our hottest spot is 25 degrees celsius
that is a massive difference now another
crazy thing
is that when this xps is just sitting
there it's using about
2 000 milliwatts or 2 watts of power you
see it fluctuating
whereas our mac it's using 26
milliwatts now let's go ahead and run
this test
and let's check out our wattage right
away wow we see 45 watts there 47 watts
cpu is at 100 degrees celsius
so the intel is getting great
performance with very high wattage
and really high heat as well our max fan
is off and it's at 64 degrees celsius so
it's staying
really cool and as far as the cpu
wattage it's using about 13 watts
and now the xps has dipped down to 27 in
order to cool off it's been about two
minutes i could definitely hear the fans
in the xps the 11 gen chip is running at
3.3 gigahertz compared to 3.2
on the mac m1 and what's interesting is
this processor has energy efficient
cores and those are about 70 degrees
celsius 69
compared to 92 for the performance
course
it's been just over five minutes and
it's interesting that the dell is now
like 19 watts 20
and it's running much cooler but the
fans are running at full
blast whereas the mac it's running
pretty hot if you take the very hottest
point of the cpu
but the fans aren't even halfway so
apple is choosing
to allow this to run hotter but stays
completely silent
compared to having loud fans and running
cooler while lowering performance
let's take another look at thermals it
looks like the xps is at 45 degrees
celsius and it has actually cooled down
quite a bit
compared to a couple minutes ago and
then our
m1 mac it's at 35 degrees celsius at its
hottest point
even though the cpu internal temps are
higher
all right we have our scores the macbook
pro got 77.04
and before we reveal the xps vadim
actually guessed
6300 i guessed 5900
let us know your thoughts right now in
the comments section below just pause
the video go type it out
and all right now that you've done that
hopefully you did
the score the xps actually got is 48.16
quite a bit lower than we expected that
means that the macbook is 60
faster under sustained cpu load which
is shocking now the reason the dell its
score is
so low lower than we expected is because
even though it starts out at 45 watts
and then drops down to 30 33
after a bit it goes down slowly it
tapers down all the way to about 17 18
watts
and instead of 3.3 gigahertz it will run
out about 2.7
and that is so weird because it cools
down the cpu and there's a lot of
thermal headroom so dell will not give
you
full performance long term on this
machine even when
it's plugged in now i want to go ahead
and unplug this i'm just going to run a
single
run instead of a 10 minute run and i'm
interested what is the full performance
you can get
if you're on battery power all right we
have our results and i actually ran
three tests which probably takes about
five six minutes
the last test we got 4228 so definitely
lower performance
now it's interesting that the first one
we ran it actually got 5200 higher than
our 10 minute stress test
but as you see as we moved on it just
gets lower and lower so if you're doing
something that's
longer than maybe two three minutes you
definitely take a hit in performance
before we take a look at photo and video
editing performance i want to do
a real life ram stress test because
the new m1 max have what apple calls
unified ram so the 16 gigs is built into
the chipset
compared to 16 gigs standard like most
computers have had it
i have about 10 tabs open here in chrome
i have a few open
in safari and edge a couple other
programs so let's go ahead and just
flick through some of these tabs over
here i have my google drive
that was pretty fast and we're getting a
little bit of glitchiness but it's still
pretty dang smooth here
let's go to our word document we have a
1080p video open
analytics there pretty dang good pretty
smooth
my 3d floor planner oh it's glitching up
all right that's good right there let's
try that out on our mac
google drive nice and perfectly smooth
word document youtube video a couple
more websites
everything is open nice and smooth
let's open up lightroom here bam both
opened
pretty much the same time let's go to
the develop tab over here
all right xps was faster now this is a
x86 application it's not yet optimized
for arm so it's running under rosetta
let's go ahead and switch to another
photo
okay i'm pretty sure i clicked it to
switch on the preview here
come on all right it's loading up right
here
bam all right so we are definitely
seeing some oh my goodness
i also have davinci resolve open here
let's click that
all right let's flick through these tabs
over here
all right we are getting some slowdowns
but still very usable on xps so far we
just have these tabs and applications
open we're not really doing anything
tough so what about for multitasking say
i'm gonna go and export these images
which will look at the speed in just a
sec the mac is on so let's go ahead and
open up
chrome again we have all our tabs video
running
no issues how about we open up davinci
resolve in the background
switch to the edit tab that is pretty
dang quick
all right we're getting some glitchiness
there
you guys can see that pretty much all
these tabs
are taking a little bit extra time now
because i have to reload it from the ssd
oh my goodness come on uh let's open up
davinci resolve like i did on the other
one
maybe go back to the edit tab
three four seconds or so to open instead
of pretty much
instant so it looks like once you start
doing other things like
rendering the background the dell does
slow down quite a bit and that unified
ram
is helping on the mac and as we're doing
that multitasking and testing
our mac is almost done with this export
whereas the dell
it's about halfway so it seems like the
not having extra ram is really limiting
it the xps finished up and it looks like
it took four minutes and 38
seconds compared to 246 so almost twice
as long and i'm curious is that because
we have
you know a bunch of tabs open another
application open or is it because of
apple's unified
ram so let's go ahead and shut down
these apps i'm gonna restart both
systems and we'll see how long it takes
with photo editing without a bunch of
other things open
and now let's look at photo editing i
just did a fresh reboot nothing else is
open in the background so we're gonna
have optimal performance
these are 42 megapixel images here
they are raw with a bunch of corrections
let's go ahead and zoom in
and i'm surprised we're getting a little
bit of glitchiness on the xps
perfectly smooth on the mac i have to
point out that the mac is actually
running this program under rosetta that
means you do lose a little bit of
performance
let's go ahead and switch between these
files so as far as speed
they're looking to be pretty dang
similar and in some cases
the mac is actually loading up faster
which is
very interesting and now let's compare
brush performance i have an exposure
brush here
nice and smooth on the mac let's look at
the xps
also nice and smooth and even if you're
using an
unoptimized app like lightroom you're
still getting great performance on the
mac
now let's go and select these images and
we are going to run an export test
again it looks like it's doing better
this time all right we have a result
and this is very interesting the macbook
took two minutes 39 seconds and the xps
took
two minutes and 44 seconds
so it looks like it's just slightly
slower than the mac
uh but way faster than when we had
other applications and chrome tabs open
whereas the unified ram
in the macbook pro it seems like it's
actually working it barely made a
difference having it
loaded with all that stuff now many of
you guys also ask us to test
building one-to-one previews so let's go
ahead and i'll click it on both we're
almost completed so far they are super
close
of course the xps fans are very loud on
the mac
it is on only if i get very close so
it's pretty much silent
alright it is finished looks like we
have 2 minutes and 58 seconds for the
mac
and 3 minutes and 12 seconds for the xps
which is interesting because this
application is optimized
for x86 processors and once it gets
updated for the mac it's going to be
even
faster and now let's get into video
editing i have davinci resolve opened on
both machines
of course on the mac you can use final
cut which is quite a bit faster
you can also use premiere on both but
premiere is very sluggish dimitri
resolve
is nice and optimized we're going to
start out by stabilizing a 20 second 4k
clip
and hit start on both of these oh
man it crashed again that's my second
time
trying to stabilize that footage and it
keeps crashing
i wonder if there's just not enough
video memory to do that effect
because with xps we have 1.5 gigs that
the graphics ship can use whereas with
the m1
the unified memory it has 16 gigs that
you could share
based on the cpu and gpu and what needs
it most
which you guys saw it was quite a bit
ahead of the xps before it crashed
yep it looks like our ram is pretty much
maxed out
just having resolve open i just reopened
it right here where it's interesting on
the mac side
we also have 16 gigs ram but only 9.79
is used but let's go ahead and do
something a little bit more simple we
have just a 4k project
open here i have some film grain applied
and some luts
let's go ahead and hit play on both of
these
and as you can see the mac is playing
back perfectly
30 frames per second whereas the xps
we are getting quite a bit of
glitchiness
so let's just go ahead and do a render
test i'm going to jump over
to our deliver tab gosh that is slow
i'm going to select intel quick sync to
speed up
our export using the hardware encoders
built into intel
cpu and let's go ahead and hit render on
both of these
it's interesting we have 12 minutes
remaining on the xps and on the mac we
have five minutes remaining
and davinci is actually pretty accurate
with their estimated time so about three
times faster
on the macbook pro and of course
this is what the xps plugged in i'm
really curious actually we're now
at oh man we're at almost 13 minutes now
i guess it's slowing down and i actually
already did this export
in my previous comparison uh and it did
finish
right at five minutes and i'm really
curious what's gonna happen if i go
ahead and unplug the xps
and it looks like actually that didn't
change anything and that is probably
because yep
we're not maxing out our cpu only about
30 use
we're more maxing out the graphics and
hitting the ram
close to max i'll plug the xps back in
and now let's wait for it to finish
all right guys the mac took five minutes
and two seconds and the dell xps
took 12 minutes and 50 seconds so a
massive difference there
and just so you guys know davinci
resolve isn't yet optimized
for apple's encoders once it is it will
take about three minutes and four
seconds
just like final cut is so as far as
video editing
if you're looking to do video editing
you should definitely get a mac
instead so there you guys go what is our
final verdict well i still recommend the
dell xps for people that want windows
that don't need mac os or don't want it
it's still a fantastic laptop and this
is
my favorite laptop i would go for the
non 201 option
you guys can check out a review if you
guys want to see that but
if you're open to using a mac system the
new 13-inch macbook pros with m1
processors
are incredible and i would highly
recommend them
not only is the performance better in
most tests or
all that we did you could do that
unplugged the battery life
is off the charts it's ridiculous if you
guys saw our other videos
you have a great track pad the display
is bright nice
and sharp and even for applications that
are not optimized yet like lightroom
the performance is still fantastic and
then when you load up the ram
it also performs better thanks to that
unified memory
so let me know your thoughts down below
i want to hear your guys's opinions i
have links to both these down
in the description there's actually sale
on sales on both and you guys can click
that circle above
if you guys want to subscribe to see
more videos check out the xps review the
standard one
and another comparison right over there
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video
you